it's that time of the month again the
six free PlayStation Plus games for
November 2016 have been announced and
although this month isn't as impressive
as last month it does offer a few
essential experiences we have
exploration b-movie action Racing
roleplay an education game and a quirky
BMX title to get you through the month
so let's kick things off with the big
guns on ps4 our first offering is the
critically acclaimed everybody's gone to
the rapture first release the year ago
the game is based in Shropshire just
down the road from where we live and
asks the player to find out why the
locals have mysteriously disappeared
there are no guns no over-the-top set
pieces nor running apart from the
occasional light jog so if you're
looking for Call of Duty s gaming steer
clear of this one but if you want to
explore a little peace of England and
become a wandering detective this one's
for you only ten months ago this title
was in many game of the Year lists so
you really should give this one a go
next up on the ps4 is the deadly Tower
of monsters originally released earlier
this year this one is a twin stick
shooter plane similarly to detonation
the plot is based on film sets of the
1970s B movies and currently holds a
Metacritic score of 73 out of 100 just
before we move on to the ps3 of Vita
please do is a huge favor by subscribing
to our content it helps keep us
motivated and more importantly allows us
to make videos just like this one right
let's go on to the ps3 and dirt 3 which
is a rally title following on from the
hugely successful Colin McCrea games
dirt 3 is 5 years old now but it still
holds up well and is perfect for Gran
Turismo fans and shares many
similarities to the old Sega Rally Games
GamesRadar gave this a whopping nine
point five out of ten astonishing also
on the ps3 is Costume Quest 2 which is a
perfect title for the Halloween season
in this how PG you'll be saving
Halloween from the evil dr. white
collect candies costumes and explore the
neighborhood at the time of the year
where no one cares if you look like a
werewolf a Viking or an Egyptian over to
the much underrated Vita where we have
letter quest remastered this title
across is a typical RPG with Scrabble
yes Scrabble battle enemies by using
your spelling prowess in this
educational
title which is surprisingly addictive
this one received favorable reviews
usually around seven out of ten finally
for the beta it's pumped BMX plus this
BMX race and trick game feels like
trials fusion and Ollie ollie mixed
together this is a casual game perfect
for your commute to school or work
levels last around 60 seconds up to
three minutes and the better you are the
quicker you are there are limited
reviews for this one so I personally
would give this six out of ten so what
are you downloading this month and what
do you think the six free games we get
for November please let us know below
these games will be available from the
1st of November so I enjoy your
Halloween evening first thanks for
watching please give us a like and maybe
subscribe to get more videos like this
one
I am Adam from felicitations grenade
I'll see you next time